okay so you have your your connection
right right here to your connection in
this body okay and the technique what
you're going to do
is go from this point of connection
to two points of connection right here
you see and now and now this is his body
this is inspired
this is not
the wwf that you're thinking
okay uh
because he can turn in on you
you go like this
and he turns in on you you see
you don't want people turning in on you
you don't give a if he gets to do
his chancey high break fall don't let
him do his fancy my breakfall do you
understand
toward that end
let me show you going in the back
because if you're in front he's gonna be
able to turn in
so get in the back stay in the back
two points to contact right here
and then step inside whatever turn he
wants to do you see how he did that
so
this is not it
puts a triangle
right into his base okay
so
let's just work on the transition to
the two points of concept so
don't worry about the adv right
oh
here i was
let go you see
and i use that energy
you see that
you don't need the hand to fall head
pull the hand you're gonna help him turn
okay
try it again okay so what are you
looking for once you touch what am i
doing in the reconciliation what's my
aim my tactical aim there
what am i trying to get
the body law you're trying to get the
body lock
okay
so the body lock is that i'm going to
tip him
and then spin him
and then have him traverse the sagittal
plane
got it then you add the stance i'm going
to make his space
do that
in a contrary direction okay we're not
dealing with the base i just want you to
see the body lock what we're not doing
is bending them over backwards people do
not bend over backwards in fights do you
understand so don't
you don't you shouldn't do that as an
uke and the worst thing you'll you'll do
is you'll try to bend backwards
when someone has the body lock on you
and you're not going to find your back
rigged fall you're just going to bite it
they're going to actually throw you okay
so
don't look
for him to bend backwards
[Music]
he is going to stay straight up
and he's going to tilt
and then he's going to rotate on that
tilt
do you understand
boom
oh
[Music]
okay
and your bend backwards
hold your posture
hold your questions
push forward fight
there's no bending push forward fight
can't bend people that are aggressive
are you turning
[Applause]
[Music]
different
okay
all right
and now we're gonna add the ademi so a
little bit of a little escape behind
when you try to bend backwards you're
not going to have anymore so try to
just hold your frame okay
so i'm coming around
contact until boom
you're going to attack the stance
okay
okay enter enter to display
have integrity on your email
yield enter
oh see i pushed you
you're pushing on this switch rolls
you